[Musique]
hey pop mmm c'est ta question
pourquoi tu ne m'as jamais aimé comme toi quelle
loi y a t'il dis que je dois t'aimer non d'
accord alors tu ne manges pas tous les jours
réponds moi quand je te parle tu ne
manges pas  tous les jours ouais tant que vous êtes dans ma
maison vous mettez une cellule au bout
quand vous me parlez oui monsieur vous mangez
tous les jours oui monsieur vous avez un toit sur la
tête oui monsieur vous avez des vêtements sur le dos
oui monsieur pourquoi vous pensez  c'est
parce que bon sang je sais que c'est à cause de moi mais pourquoi penses-
tu que c'est
parce que tu m'aimes comme toi je sors d'
ici tous les matins je me casse les fesses pourrais-
je
t'aimer  est censé prendre soin de sa
famille tu vis dans ma maison pour ton
ventre avec ma nourriture mets ton derrière sur mon
lit parce que tu es mon fils c'est
mon devoir de prendre soin
de toi  pour t'aimer maintenant je
ne te donne pas tout ce que j'ai à
te donner je te donne ta vie moi et ta
maman arrangeons ça entre nous et comme
dans ton cul noir  ne faisait pas partie du
marché maintenant ne passez vous pas par la vie à vous
soucier de savoir si quelqu'un vous aime
ou non vous feriez mieux de vous assurer
qu'ils font ce qu'il faut pour vous vous
comprenez ce que je dis
tout ce que ce garçon fait pour  toi
ce n'est pas facile pour moi d'admettre que je
me tiens au même endroit depuis 18
ans en comprenant avec toi
j'ai donné 18 ans de ma vie pour me tenir
au même endroit que toi
[Musique]